I grew up during the late 60s and 70s
that's when I started to take things in
golf was a way for a guy to just be
ridiculous Johnny Miller Lee Trevino
Jack Nicklaus Tom Watson it was all
about plaid patchwork I wanted to dress
like I saw those guys dressed when I was
growing up so I found some like the
wildest fabric I could find I just
thought there are other guys out there
like me this is just something that's
waiting to happen
being the NBA that I was not I figured
out that if I could just sell 11 pants
per day I could replace my salary as a
freelance graphic designer
and I could just do this full-time the
company was just self-funded for the
first six years the second mortgage home
line of credit
I sewed customer service I shipped
fortunately there was a loudmouth
customer that came along gave me a call
and said hey what what are you doing
here you're spinning your wheels why
don't you come down we'll play around
the golf because I'm interested in your
company on the front nine we talked
about the problems that he had supply
money inventory and by the end of the
day we had a little napkin deal worked
out woody you put it on your computer
screen I'll figure out how to turn it
into good quality pants and sell we
found a manufacturer that was willing to
work with us they were now my designs
put on fabric printed in bulk made by
real people that makes real clothes
the golf industry is a finite group of
people and we thought early on that we
were gonna have to do something extra
licensing started to pop up now we have
about 25 different licensees with
products all over the map from golfing
products to lifestyle products like iPad
and iPhone covers loudmouth wine bedding
and baths this year we'll do 10 million
bucks in business I would expect
royalties to be 10 to 20 percent of our
business in two years there are an
infinite number of color combinations
out there there's an infinite number of
shapes I look at anything I say hmm that
would look like I'm fair pants